thanks to her reporting out there some
republicans meanwhile calling for
new york governor andrew cuomo to resign
all of this after the state's attorney
general released a report
claiming that new york under counted its
nursing home
coronavirus deaths by as much as 50
percent
congresswoman elise stefanik is accusing
the governor of being involved in a
cover-up
i am calling on the democratic state
senators as well as the republican state
senators to immediately issue those
subpoenas
and the department of justice to issue
those subpoenas i'm also calling on
president biden to publicly state
that there will be an independent
investigation and not play
politics with this mike lawler is a new
york state assemblyman and partner at
checkmate strategist
mike thanks for being here this
afternoon just tragic what happened here
to learn of these many nursing home
deaths that went uncounted
in this process and new york governor's
not taking responsibility for that we
all saw the news conference last week
shouldn't we all be demanding more
answers and have the doj look into this
further
well absolutely and thank you for having
me sandra you know
last week the governor said incompetent
government kills people
and tish james confirmed it and you know
what we've seen here
is a governor who says one thing and
does another
he said when he asked for and received
full unilateral control
of the pandemic response in new york
that we should blame him if something
goes wrong
and now when uh it's revealed that
something did in fact go wrong
and people are blaming him he instead
wants to blame everybody else he wants
to blame the federal government he wants
to blame the hospitals he wants to blame
the nursing homes
he wants to blame law enforcement and he
wants to blame
nursing home residents many of whom
unfortunately died as a result of his
directive that he issued on march 25th
of last year mandating that nursing
homes take
uh coveted positive patients and and
house them in their nursing homes and as
the attorney general's report
uh showed it resulted in thousands more
uh patients being infected and
ultimately unfortunately dying
and what is clear is that the governor
and his administration
uh spent months trying to cover this up
and hide the true
total numbers of covet positive patients
and death counts coming from the nursing
homes
it's horrific and and we heard him in
his own words
dismissing what we all learned with that
report last week here was his briefing
listen when i say experts
in air quotes
it sounds like i'm saying i don't really
trust the experts
because i don't because i don't
so in addition to elise stefanik the
republican congresswoman from new york
who you just heard a moment ago speaking
out
against this lee zeldin another new york
congressman
he's not just calling this a cover-up
he's saying this is criminal what
happened
listen this is a cover-up
and it's a cover-up of a policy that
ended up resulting in that gran
grandmother grandfather losing their
lives who was involved in covering up
the numbers
as the timeline move forward in the
weeks and months that followed and they
want not just more information and
transparency they also want
accountability i mean this is criminal
so how far do you see this going
ultimately where will they take it well
you know many years ago the governor
said i
am the government and so he has nobody
to blame here but himself
as i said he asked for and received
unilateral control
in response to this pandemic i'm calling
on the
speaker carl hasty and the majority
leader andrea stewart cousins to
immediately
revoke those emergency powers that this
governor was granted
and to join their colleagues on the
other side of the aisle in
demanding a joint hearing and
investigation so that we can get to the
bottom of this and uh we should be
subpoenaing the commissioner of health
occur we should be subpoenaing his uh
executive staff
and ultimately the governor needs to be
held accountable for the decisions that
he has
made during this pandemic because mike
you have heard firsthand from so many of
those families who lost
loved ones who are demanding answers and
they want to know more
why this happened thanks for joining us
question thank you